thomas merci bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france on le visait
les autorités australiennes qui ont
annoncé hier donc la détection lui à
rians au micron est ce qu'on en sait un
peu plus ce matin est ce qu'il ya des
mesures qui ont été annoncées
alors on a détecté depuis dimanche
dernier deux cas de micron de chaos
micron dimanche dernier donc il n'a eu 2
à sydney et un dans l'état des northern
territory les territoires du nord de
l'australie
alors comment ça se passe à partir du
moment où ça a été détectée
alors pour le moment ils sont vraiment
en attente de savoir quel est l'effet de
ceux de ce variant de comics 19 donc ils
ont mis en place différentes réunions
les frontières à l'heure actuelle ne
sont pas encore fermés les décisions
seront prises dans les jours à venir
c'est un peu trop tôt encore pour savoir
quelles mesures de contrainte ils vont
mettre en place les seules mesures
aujourd'hui sont pour les personnes
vaccinées arrivant sur le territoire
australien doivent se soumettre à 72
heures de quarantaine et un test
également pour pour vérifier s'ils n'ont
pas se marier alors pour eux pour cette
mise en quarantaine il ya eu des
dispositifs qui avait fait l'objet de
rumeurs la semaine dernière où
l'australie aurait misé en place des
décors justement pour mettre les
personnes contaminées c'est sur le sueur
sur volontariat que ces personnes se
sont mises à l'isolément dans ces camps
spécifiques
alors il y avait eu il ya quelques mois
un projet de construire des hôtels de
quarantaine notamment à l'extérieur de
melbourne je crois que le projet a été à
l'arrêt sinon c'est dans les territoires
du nord de l'australie où il ya une
communauté aborigène assez importante
c'est une population très fragile les
militaires ont été appelés en renfort
pour pouvoir distribuer de la nourriture
procéder à des vaccinations et également
à des tests donc il ya environ 60 comme
unitaire aujourd'hui qu'ils sont ont été
déployés dans les territoires du nord
pour contrôler pour vérifier que tout le
monde aille bien puisqu'en effet les
populations aborigènes sont très très
fragile notamment face aux communes 19
les populations qui sont très fragiles
pourquoi elles ne peuvent pas ciseaux et
elles vivent les unes avec les autres ce
qui rend compliqué finalement la lutte
contre la propagation du virus
exactement il ya différentes communautés
aborigènes qui vivent très proches l'une
de l'autre donc aujourd'hui ces
communautés sont en quarantaine elles
sont en ce qu'on appelle en lockdown
elles sont confits demandons qu'elles ne
peuvent pas communiquer entre elles et
donc il ya quand même un contrôle pour
éviter la propagation
aujourd'hui on peut dire que c'est
relativement sous contrôle il ya et 58
cas actifs dans les neurones territory
alors c'est vrai que vu de france on se
demande pourquoi 58 car c'est sais rien
mais pour une communauté qui est fragile
c'est assez important c'est un
territoire qui est assez désertique où
on est loin de tout donc c'est pour ça
que l'armée a été rappelé en renfort
pour pouvoir aider ces communautés et
notamment pour délibérer pour pour
livrer de la nourriture et apporter tout
leur soutien également psychologique aux
aborigènes d'australie qu'elle ait
choisi la stratégie zéro commune on s'en
souvient avec des déconfinement assez
stricte aujourd'hui est-ce que
l'australie revoit sa politique et et
encourage aussi la vaccination
la vaccination à l'instar des autres
pays
exactement alors notamment dans l'état
du victoria à melbourne nous avons eu un
des lots d'armes les plus importants au
monde ont atteint 265 jours donc ça a
été ça a été très très long et compliqué
pour les habitants de melbourne
aujourd'hui la vaccination c'est la
priorité c'est pour ces raisons qu'on a
aujourd'hui 90% de vacciner dans l'état
du victoria nettement un petit peu plus
je crois qu'on est à 94 pour cent de la
nouvelle galles du sud à sydney là on
trouve la ville de sydney et on a pu
retrouver entre guillemets une vie
normale donc plus de masques à
l'extérieur retour de l'ouverture des
restaurants des commerces et ça depuis
pour l'état du victoria plus depuis
quelques jours seulement et du coup quel
est l'état d'esprit de la population
australienne aujourd'hui a pas de
psychose avec l'arrivée de ce nouveau
variant
les australiens sont réconciliés en cr
qui vont très facilement porter le
masque sans que ce soit une obligation
donc dans la rue on va avoir beaucoup de
gens avec le masque alors qu'il n'est
plus obligatoire et les distances la
distance sociale entre les personnes et
toujours respecté donc on a toujours ce
fameux mètre cinquante
et donc il ya cette conscience des
australiens naturel à pouvoir mettre en
place des règles sens qu'elle soit
obligatoire donc oui à une certaine peur
parce que d'un point de vue culturel
l'australie n'a jamais vécu avec un
virus auparavant d'ailleurs dans
l'histoire d'australie on trouve
régulièrement des attelles quarantaine
sur les côtes puisqu'ils veulent
éliminer tout tout tout virus et c'est
une grande première au niveau de
l'histoire d'australie de laisser
finalement le qu'ovide 19 circulé mais
mettre en place des campagnes de
vaccination importante
merci beaucoup te remercier pour toutes
ces précisions thomas mercier en direct
de melbourne ce matin